[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga this week
70 years to the day after Israel was
founded the u.s. reversed decades of
American foreign policy and took action
to make the recognition of Jerusalem as
Israel's capital official by formally
relocating its embassy to Jerusalem and
sending president Trump's daughter
Ivanka with her husband Jared Kushner to
inaugurate the new premises a triumph
for some Israelis but a bitter
provocation for many Palestinians who
see Jerusalem as their own capital their
mass attempt to cross the border fence
separating Israel from Gaza turned into
the bloodiest protest in years coming
just after Trump's announcement that the
US will no longer comply with the Iran
nuclear agreement but instead reimpose
sanctions the embassy launch was the
second move with highly disruptive
implications for the already volatile
Middle East can and should Europe
counter Trump and the Middle East any
role for Europe that's our topic and
these are our guests it's a pleasure to
welcome
Nora Musa she is executive director of
international affairs at the curva
Foundation and she says after Trump's
decisions in the Middle East the
Europeans must do damage control and
very glad to have on the program Shani
rosana's she was born in Israel is a
producer and Middle East analyst here at
DW and she says to divided and
self-involved Europe is systematically
failing to fill the void left by
American policy and finally very glad to
have back on the program
Alan Posner he's an author for the daily
newspaper here in Germany Deven and he
says Europe and America are strong when
they act together when they don't
America is weakened and Europe becomes
invisible so Allen more than 50 deaths
2,400 people injured on Monday on this
program you vigorously defended the u.s.
decision to relocate the embassy at the
end of last year that decision taken
then and I'm wondering do you abide by
that opinion in the face of this
bloodshed absolutely more than ever
look this bloodshed has nothing to do
with the moving of the embassy this
bloodshed was planned by Hamas and its
Iranian backers for over a year
this march of return which means
Reconquista of Israel has been planned
by Hamas as I say for over a year they
they it's to mark what they called Nakba
day the day of the catastrophe the day
that Israel was founded and many
Palestinians lost their home and they
wanted they've been wanting these more
martyrs for months and months and they
planned towards that and there would
have been violence at the at the border
anyway no matter what mr. Trump did or
didn't do so please do not conflate
these two issues of the movement of the
of the of the of the embassy to
Jerusalem which is a perfectly peaceful
just putting on a new plaque on an honor
building it already stands there and and
this terrible incitement by Hamas to
send people to enter their deaths at the
border the Palestinians who stormed the
fence did have multiple reasons to be
frustrated including the weakness and
corruption of their own administration
and of course Israel's intransigence so
can we really lay this violence at
Donald Trump's door as many people have
been doing well I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't argue that it is only to be
blamed on Donald Trump I think there are
multiple other reasons for the
Palestinians to be frustrated but I do
believe that the embassy movement to
Jerusalem is of a very inflammatory
nature and I think it's not for no
reason that the issue of Jerusalem has
been delayed in in the peace
negotiations between Palestinians and
Israelis to the final status talks so I
think creating facts on the ground which
not are not only facts on the ground but
which are to the benefit of just one
party to the conflict without actually
giving a similar concession a similarly
important concession to the other side
is a a highly problematic move and the
question you ask is why why would the
Americans do that at this point in time
because it's unclear to me what what is
the return on investment if you will so
I think that is that is a question we
really have to ask to to to Washington
and I want to ask that question about
timing in just a moment but Shani Rosen
is first of all Donald Trump has
defended Israel's use of force on Monday
but there has been widespread
condemnation elsewhere of what critics
say was a very disproportionate use of
live ammunition against mostly unarmed
protesters Amnesty International has
called it a scandalous violation of both
international law and human rights how
do you see it well there's there's no
doubt that the Americans supporter
backing of Israeli moves when it comes
to Gaza but not just cuz of course and
it keeps Israeli is much more calm even
when we see a lot of POTUS coming from
Europe because as we could see on Monday
with the with the moving of the plaque
yes it's just a plaque but of course the
symbol behind it and that all that
matters in the middle is the symbol is
quite great the symbolism is amazing so
in that aspect we could see that
ceremony is cementing that bond that
conservative religious bond between
Israel and America and as long as
Israel's got America's backing they feel
quite fine and solid and quiet despite
the fact that of course this is quite
controversial and rightfully so
and we also need to keep in mind Hamas
themselves have their stories not really
aligned you know at the beginning the
the the first explanation was these are
all harmless people unarmed but then
Hamas spokesperson himself yesterday
confirmed that 50 out of the casualties
were actually Hamas people so they're in
that way shooting their own arguments in
the lag in not being too persistent with
their claim of what has happened so
controversial yes but always it always
is in this region you know so the date
that was chosen for this symbolic and
controversial controversial move was in
fact the time of year when tensions
between Israel
Palestinians are at their highest
anniversary of Israel's founding and
anniversary of the Palestinian expulsion
the question is should the US have known
it was adding fuel to a fire let's hear
what the main protagonists had to say
about the decision this is a great day
for Israel it's a great day for America
[Music]
it's a great day for our fantastic
partnership but I believe it's also a
great day for peace Israel is a
sovereign nation with the right like
every other sovereign nation to
determine its own capital the United
States remains fully committed to
facilitating a lasting peace agreement
[Music]
what we saw Jerusalem today was not the
opening of an embassy but the opening of
an American settlement outpost Allen
hasn't the US in essence given up any
pretense of being impartial or being in
the role of an arbiter between the two
sides and if so what are the
consequences of that for the peace
process um America I hope was never
impartial as regards Israel and I wish
Europe would be less impartial because
it's perfectly clear that the position
of the West has to be on the side of the
regions only functioning democracy
Israel 70 years of democracy never been
in doubt although the state itself as
hard as has been attacked time and time
again by its neighbors surely that's a
reason not to be impartial if the Arabs
want to come to a peace deal they have
to realize and Europe needs to send this
message to that Israel isn't going to go
away and it's friends aren't going to go
away from it so they're not impartial we
are friends of the Israelis we're not
necessarily with certainly not friends
of hamas and we're not friends of mr.
Abbas who just recent
he said that the juice is responsible
for the Holocaust I mean come on don't
we have any principles here surely if we
have any principles at all it means
Stanly behind Israel I'm telling the
other side we are here what are you
giving us no matter how do you see it I
think from a German point of view of
course it's clear that Israel's security
is proud of our lizand a time that's
that what what the Chancellor said in
the Knesset I think it was back in 2008
with this said however I do believe that
we we have because the Israelis are our
friends and because we feel that they're
going wrong when it comes to settlement
activities and all of that that we have
to be critical in in that regard and I
think that is that is at the core of our
engagement in the Middle East peace
process so I I would say that yes I mean
the Americans have taken themselves out
of the game in terms of um you know
their ability to be an honest broker to
some extent and yes this would be the
European moment to jump in and to take
over that role I I wouldn't necessarily
say that we don't have any tools in our
armed diplomatic toolbox visa V the
parties to the conflict I am Not sure
however whether you know the Europeans
can fill that vacuum that that was left
by by Washington let me come back to
that in just a moment because we do have
a soundbite from Angela Merkel on that
and other issues but let me first ask
you Shawnee two questions first of all
Israel as a democracy some people worry
that if we go on much longer without
something like a two-state solution or
some other outcome of a peace process
that Israel may find itself forced to
choose between being a democracy and
being a Jewish state so would you say in
fact there is urgency here in terms of
where the so-called dormant peace
process is going I think what you're
saying is exactly the point and this is
where we we need to put you know the
emphasis between what Ellen and Nour is
saying
there is more than one way to be
pro-israel you know and Alan takes one
stand which is let's say pro-regime
pro-government it takes a very clear
stand its backing not only Israel as a
state but also this particular
government and its policy while Nora is
saying we can be pro-israel and we can
say and watch Peter so there is more
than one way if we feel and then many
people within Israel there are many loud
voices within Israel saying settlements
are not conducive not to the peace
process not to Israel not for Israel's
own future if we don't want to
jeopardize the Jewish majority of the
state and allow it to be a separate
state and not one state you know which
we it will might end up being if you
look at the demographics look at the
numbers
with so many Palestinians inside and
then if we don't want to give the
Palestinians their rights what how can
we still claim to be a democracy so this
very discussion is in the heart of what
we're talking about and there is no
doubt that you this current regime does
not feel that the the the too much of a
rush you know they're knowing they have
a backing of the White House at least
for the next probably maybe four eight
years but definitely for the next two or
three more years and Netanyahu himself
if you see if you look at his policy if
you try to answer what he's been doing
so far his strategy is waiting waiting
it out seeing how the rest of the Arab
world is you know where does this go
especially following the Arab Spring and
the unrest that followed that but this
is what he believes is the right thing
to do I'm I'm not certain there's so
many voices within Israel that
necessarily think it's the only way we
should go or or this is the smartest way
who should go
Alan Posner Donald Trump is a firm
believer that disruption can produce
surprisingly constructive results and
the fact is conventional diplomacy has
so far essentially achieved only a
stalemate
so how confident are you that by shaking
things up he can in some way reactivate
something like a constructive peace
process I'm very confident actually
because it's not true actually that the
conventional diplomacy is created a
stalemate conventional diplomacy over
the eight years of the Obama
administration has created a catastrophe
for everyone concerned in the in the
Middle East look at Syria No
at the situation of the Palestinians
look at Yemen look at the rise of Iran I
mean terror look at Lebanon terrible
situation all caused by doing nothing so
shaking that do nothing approach up and
saying okay we're we are we are putting
everything on the table now let's see
you deliver it's already working look
after Trump said we're moving the
embassy to Jerusalem up came Prince
Salman of Saudi Arabia Salman bin of
Mohammed and said said to Abbas
personally and publicly you need to
recognize Israel finally and deal with
the reality our see see the the
president of Egypt tried to convince mr.
hanya of Hamas not to do these
demonstrations you can see already how
the perception of America as being firm
and not some kind of putting nail to the
wall is is is forcing the Arabs to face
up to reality if this is good not bad
also was the one who said we will never
and neutralized our relationship with
Israel as long as there's no solution to
the Palestinian problem you know he's
being very cautious and it's true that
Saudis that you can see the salaries in
one clear alliance with Israel because
we have that Iran is the big devil
bringing Washington and and and of
course Israel and Saudi Arabia together
but it's it's if you still feel that the
Palestinians can be the one who deliver
a peace proper you know a peace deal to
the Middle East I wish I could have your
optimism I think I think you're
delusional
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna interrupt us
right there cuz I want to take us back
to our topic of Europe's role and I
mentioned a soundbite from Angela Merkel
so let's listen to that if we look at
the region at a whole she had some
rather self-critical remarks to make
during her first speech to the
Parliament after being sworn in for
another term as Chancellor
let's hear and what was in Europe is
directly impacted by this situation at
the same time we've not done enough to
try and work out a political solution to
this dispute I acknowledge that if god I
have no illusions about the complexities
of this situation but I believe that we
must become
involved in resolving this dispute and
Germany will do that not a Miller I
guess you agree that Germany should do
more because you wrote in your book on
female diplomacy and you also referred
in your opening statement to damage
control but what exactly would that mean
in this case what very concretely could
and should Germany and Europe you doing
look I think this whole talk about the
deal of the century and the ultimate
deal that we've we've been hearing from
Washington now in regard to Iran oh no
no I'm sorry which deal do you mean
there Donald Trump talks a lot about a
lot of you know I was referring back to
you to our previous topic because really
Palestinian continent I just wanted to
add that I don't believe in the idea of
you know this this big deal this
ultimate deal that that Trump has been
promising I think where Europe can come
in is you know um taking us back to two
realities on the ground and making small
steps more you know opting for a more of
an incremental approach I sometimes use
the the image of a marathon at this
point in time because peace doesn't seem
to be around the corner I think we have
to opt more for a shorter run than for
the 42 kilowatt kilometer marathon
meaning that Europe for example could
propose um a more incremental approach
where we trust where we can start
rebuilding trust between the parties to
the conflict that could be on the
Israeli side maybe a freeze freeze of
settlements no more on construction work
beyond the green line whereas on the
Palestinian side there could be an end
to the payments to you to so-called
mattress families these could be you
know very initial steps that could could
help rebuild trust and and there is a
role for Europe to be played there I
think Shani Amazonas you said in your
opening statement to that so far you
don't see Europe stepping into the void
what would you want to see them do well
I think first of all the using of the
term Europe is misleading what's Europe
you know what you put right now we still
have
in there but that's not gonna last for
too long the European Union themselves
we're talking about Austria Czech Czech
Republic Hungary and Romania who sent
their delegates quite proudly to join
the Americans this week with the
aggregation of the embassy they're part
of the you are they going to be
supporting every step that the tusks or
Yunker or mogherini are bringing what is
the EU if you look at the dominant
forces if you look at it two dominant
leaders and you see McKown obviously
from France and you see I'm gonna mark
it here they are also quite I mean
McKown is very you know he's young he's
energetic he has all these initiatives
you want to bring France into as much as
I mean we've seen a great deal of him
done in the last year that he's in
office but then we see Angela Merkel is
receding in the sitting German Foreign
Policy is actually about doing as less
as we can we're talking about Marathon
know they're not even putting their
shoes on we're a bunch of people are
bandwagon there is no clear policy for
the EU let me just come in on very
briefly if you would because I really
want to get us to Iran when you look at
the run and when you look at European
efforts to keep up the jcpoa the
agreement the nuclear agreement exactly
the the nuclear agreement I think that's
just that's so much more than just
putting our shoes on right the Europeans
really do you try to stand up to you to
to the Americans to some extent although
that's not a position that we want to be
in I mean we want to be in a working
transatlantic partnership but here we
are and we see mogherini and we see the
the German the the French and and and
the British Foreign Minister stand up
together and and trying to work out how
we can how we can salvage that's that
deal that is in our own security
interest by the way we have a very short
report on where things stand with you
Iran let's just take a look at that
Germany Britain and France are still
committed to the Iran nuclear deal
there are foreign ministers will work
with Iran to try to keep it alive last
does this agreement directly effects the
security interests of Europe without
this Agreement there will be more
insecurity and uncertainty about
developments in Iran and the near and
Middle East the deal lifts economic
sanctions on Iran provided that Tehran
limits its nuclear activities and allows
international inspectors to verify
compliance but now president Trump has
restored the old sanctions and
threatened to impose new ones on
businesses that trade with Iran we are
going to see whether the political will
that has been expressed by the remaining
participants in jcpoa can be translated
into specific actions and we will see
them thank you the US has stepped up the
pressure on the Europeans can they stand
up to Washington
[Music]
Owen they claim they want to do just
that they revived something called a
blocking resolution a tactic that was
used in regard to Cuba sanctions
essentially telling European companies
not to comply with new US sanctions can
that possibly be effective and you
talked about Europe and the u.s. working
together is there any possible
compromise you see out there well what
what what a pass if we come to the judge
asking this question the point is your
if Europe leaders had any sense they
would have left the deal to because the
only way we can put pressure on Iran to
actually comply with the deal is by
reimposing the sanctions and then saying
look we want you to do this Iran is not
complaining all they say is that they
enriching the amount of uranium that
they are allowed to enrich but they are
not complying with the deal as far as
there are also Security Council
resolutions about the missiles allowed
to buy they're not complying that there
are Security Council resolutions about
they're not allowed to supply any
weapons to Hizballah's 50,000 rockets
how long do we want to stand by well one
country thus dismisses everything and we
still give the money which is basically
what what getting rid of sanctions means
we are funding people who want to kill
us and come on we need the US has talked
about trying to bring those other issues
into some sort of larger package
Europeans were willing to talk about
that were they not I think we have to
create a bit of order here I think the
the the nuclear deal the jcpoa is a
non-proliferation arms control deal
which has nothing to do with Iran's
regional activities which has nothing to
do with ballistic missiles with human
rights those are separate issues I think
it is very important as you said Ellen
to address these issues visa via the
Iranians and I do believe that the
Europeans also have a role to
play there because unlike the Americans
they have channels they have ways and
means to talk to terror on the Americans
yes have we had up to now with these
incredible channels I always hear about
we have to strengthen the Reformers in
Iran the Reformers aren't in power the
people who are in power are people who
want to eliminate Israel and who are
building missiles which can reach Europe
I mean what what what back channels let
me bring Shawn eros honest into this
place because we're very close to the
end of our program here Shani Trump is
banking on the idea that it's possible
to get a much better comprehensive deal
with Iran on all of these points what do
you think is the likelihood of that with
the transfers are slim to none because
had he wanted to improve the dealer he
should have stayed on a you know should
have stayed with the negotiations and
say let's try to find a way to do that
but he's being very harsh I don't think
you know I'm also looking at Trump's
record he's promising better deals when
it comes to Paris climate agreement he's
promised better deals when he came to
Obama care and could talking about
better health care for Americans he's
really good with tarnishing with
existing I haven't seen him finding
constructive better solutions yet so let
me ask you this coming back to the
European move you said you want to see
bolder action from the EU are you
satisfied with this new call for this
blocking resolution that would tell
European companies hey don't go along
with the US sanctions and if so who's
going to indemnify them for their losses
well it's a great question I think I
mean I think this resolution it just
shows the helplessness of Europe you
know they're being desperate they're
grasping at straws and this is what they
could come up with its but as you're
saying yourself the way to implement it
the way to enforce it very limited and
I'm not sure Europeans have the guts to
go into this trade war with America I'm
not sure they can last there I want to
see the show to end on this note I think
the the blocking statute is just one
part of a wider package that the
Europeans are trying to put together to
salvage the jcpoa so I think that's
important to stress here Alan Posner one
sentence are we seeing irreparable
divisions between the US and your
if Europe doesn't get its act together
yes only Europe yeah definitely Europe
we need to deliver and be hard on the
Iranians and not on the Americans we're
choosing the wrong the wrong enemy thank
you very much thanks to all of you for
being with us and thanks to you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]